hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Wade once again say hi
Wade
hi guys that's all yeah okay alright
that's it so much geez we're gonna play
screeching I mean you oh come on one
more Tyler now you're one overturned
youtuber way to and what did you get the
for the commuting clean for the Queen it
was an inside joke just like I've got
dude we're playing cards please don't
judge us but we're playing screen cheap
because we just got done playing rocket
League and we're looking for other co-op
games in considering we were just
playing split-screen
and I love split screen gaming it's one
of my favorite item like harkening back
to like Goldeneye for the n64 is that
thing
don't ask okay you don't even know so in
this game we have no idea where each
other are we don't show up in the game
world for each other so we have to
scritchy Oh
we even have to look at the Oliver I'm
gonna cheat on your yeah yeah oh gee yep
whoa whoa hey you get out here you're in
there whoa
someone oh god you're scared you know
you're so scared ah
I killed me am i I was like some weird
lady no we're you know we're and
everywhere oh I don't know why are you
finished no I don't know either
you can't win I have the high ground
[ __ ] kiss-kiss you don't have the high
Gotham oh yeah are you worried we're
holding down who are you I don't know
where are you do we right yeah yeah are
you where are you human hello guy okay
boom Oh No
the Movida oh okay do something ah
okay I'm not very good this year we
actually never played this game oh we've
never played this game before in our
lives so it's really weird to see like
just how this game actually what are you
oh yeah why man I'm like a crow man you
keep looking at my body whoa oh please
please Klingon cities have a max range
okay wow that was really fun
solve your clues to score points what I
don't know does that mean don't without
why are we three out of four when we're
taping now what happen in history what
what are we playing wait okay for what
your target is blue okay it is red
oh wait blunderbuss one okay I don't
whoa someone here there's someone here
there's someone here there's someone
among me there's someone among me
yay what did I do it I don't know dope
what the hell was that oh we're getting
it no okay
oh well then show your your he wasn't my
target oh okay I get it
whoa my target change did I kill my
target
Argus you oh goodness creamy oh these
guys might be good maybe we shouldn't
have laid online
target is red I need to kill with the
trappler okay I need to kill this deal
ah Oh what are they what if one of one I
don't know how this works I don't know
how this works
don't I don't know they don't understand
whoa Wow yay I did it cool dumb dead oh
man we just gotta look better I think
okay what I'm saying is that you're ugly
horrendous ly ugly but what if how does
this work just duh you get to hit Chris
wrong target I'm not gonna kill yellow
with the originator I don't you tell
work and here you gotta do what now I
gotta kill yellow with the work inator
here it is with the yoruba with some
fava bean nice it was got him hey all
right
so target is so insane this is insanity
don't mind me I'm just going up for the
rifling oh there we go wait okay yellow
is red right how do I know which come
out red you how did I not kill him how
did I not kill him damn it new terribly
I'm really giving away my location right
now oh did I know
whoa [ __ ] I don't know if I killed the
right person they're in it oh I don't
know where oh oh yeah you were my target
was I yeah I hope you aah
no no excuse me
Wow I got a double kill apparently green
with a blunder who was it how do you
even use the trap horror I don't know
now you cool alone Oh on when we dreamed
of you Oh God well that's a bizarre
locket a lot of me oh he's among me I
think I think I'm going the wrong way
okay you're down there by a mice mi know
mi badger am i down here am i why do you
keep jumping down you things ah I don't
know I don't understand how that weapon
works uh where'd you go I didn't go
anywhere are you talking about me or
someone else I'm gonna kill Robert
everyone watching this is probably way
less confused by Arno confused I'm so
conveyed to so we need the rifle to kill
you dude what was that I don't know - I
certain to win Jo someone's going to win
well who's doing that no not that who's
who's there who's there
my brain hurts if I continue in my brain
oh no no no no no we're never done real
okay good because that was confusing so
confuse were two how do we get out back
no how do we get out get out
Boop all right I guess we're thank you
everybody so much for watching you guys
are awesome this game is confusing but
probably fun when you're playing with
friends so no play with online strangers
hey I'm so good I won anyway right wait
thanks again as always we'll see if an
extra bicycle kick we would already play
that [ __ ] yes we're gonna win